[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous notre monde est dans un
monde en changement
vous le savez tous les façons de
travailler et évoluer sont aujourd'hui
multiples il ya de nos jours possible de
vivre ses rêves au travail et d'avoir un
travail de rêve en 2017
j'ai décidé de me lancer à mon compte et
de devenir indépendant devenant ainsi on
va dire le le capitaine de mon propre
navire ou plutôt de mon petit bateau
entreprenariale puisque comme vous
l'avez entendu dans la présentation je
suis tout seul à bord avec ce changement
s'est imposée peu à peu une gestion du
temps différente une gestion ou temps
professionnel et en personnel sont
devenus deux voisins au mur extrêmement
poreux qui se confond de même
quelquefois de là et bien on fait le
constat
premier constat le temps c'est de
l'argent vous le savez tous nous passons
un temps important à travailler dans le
but de gagner de l'argent
cette rémunération est ensuite utilisée
pour subvenir à nos besoins financer nos
projets financés nos loisirs
oui mais voilà deuxième constat qu'il
n'y a pas que le travail dans la vie et
si c'était le cas eh bien on serait
riches tous très très riches mais on
aurait pas de temps libre pour dépenser
cet argent
cet argent qu'on a mis du temps la sueur
et du sang de temps en temps mais a
gagné donc nous voilà devant on va dire
un paradoxe on appeler ça comme ça
il nous faut à la fois du temps et de
l'argent et vous allez me dire comment
faire en sorte de conseiller ce qui
semble être à première vue un paradoxe
eh bien c'est exactement ce que je vous
propose d'explorer dans ce toc
alors en tant qu'indépendant ce qui fait
ma force c'est ma valeur ajoutée la
valeur ajoutée c'est ce qui me permet de
gagner de l'argent et c'est aussi pour
ça que mes clients me choisisse mois
plutôt qu'un autre
cette valeur ajoutée elle s'élève sur
deux piliers
premier pilier nos valeurs celles que
l'on se choisit et qu'on doit être en
mesure de faire mieux que les autres de
maîtriser mieux que les autres et 2e
pilier l'expérience c'est à dire on va
dire la somme de tout ce qu'on a vécu de
tout ce que l'on a mené et qui est
propre
évidemment à chacun de nous c'est ça qui
vous différencie les expériences
professionnelles
alors ça c'est évident mais pas que on
n'entend pas mal de choses vous savez
quand vous parlez avec les gens qui
sortent de là de la fac ou même des
professionnels mais n'oubliez jamais que
quand vous dites notre vie
professionnelle
on entend avant tout notre vie on entend
avant tout notre vie et c'est les
expériences professionnelles
ils sont en premier lieu des expériences
de vie à ce propos il est vraiment temps
que les recruteurs se réveille alors
vous qui êtes jeunes comme moi ça va pas
durer
vous avez très certainement entendu dire
merci pour votre candidature
mais après étude de cette dernière
il s'avère que
vous n'avez pas été retenu pour ce poste
puisque vous manqué d'expérience voilà
je vais vous raconter une anecdote une
anecdote intéressante
j'ai rencontré il n'y a pas si longtemps
quelqu'un qui a perdu sa mère à 18 ans
qui a perdu son père l'année suivante
quelqu'un qui chaque jour pendant quatre
ans s'est levé à 5 heures du matin pour
prendre le même train de 6h37 simplement
pour travailler et étudier dans les
universités de son choix
quelqu'un qui a travaillé chaque été
dans un fast food
depuis ses 16 ans pour gagner de quoi
financer une formation parallèle
quelqu'un qui est parti vivre à
l'étranger parce que je vous conseille
d'ailleurs si vous pouvez partir en
erasmus par exemple et bien fait là
alors cette personne est parti à
l'étranger elle s'est retrouvée dans une
culture qu'elle ne connaissait pas elle
s'est parfaitement intégré dans ce monde
elle a pris cette culture et dès son
retour en france
cette personne a lancé son projet et a
généré en deux ans seuls près de 100000
euros de chiffre d'affaires et 7
personnes manqueraient pour les
recruteurs d'expérience ils doutent de
sa capacité d'engagement et de sa force
de conviction pour défendre les intérêts
de leurs entreprises
ils craignent que cette personne ait du
mal à intégrer le fonctionnement de
cette même entreprise et ils doutent de
sa capacité à fédérer
je vous laisse comprendre un petit peu
les logiques de recrutement aujourd'hui
c'est tout ce que vous vivez qui vous
forge et vous façonne et pas simplement
votre expérience professionnelle et
retenez bien une chose une expérience
professionnelle vous serre la plupart du
temps dans votre travail
alors qu'une expérience de vie vous
servira partout travail compris voltaire
termine l'un des chapitres clés de son
oeuvre quand guide sur ces mots il faut
cultiver votre jardin il faut cultiver
votre jardin c'est à dire prendre le
temps de vivre
prendre le temps de s'élever c'est cela
le véritable combustible de votre valeur
ajoutée
oui mais voilà pour entretenir cette
expérience est donc cette valeur ajoutée
qui est gage de créativité et bien il
vous faut du temps il vous faut le temps
de vivre
la véritable relation de cause à effet
entre temps et argent se trouvait dans
la notion de rémunération alors faisons
simple votre rémunération est bien c'est
avant tout nous sommes davantage la
plupart du temps versée en argent
cet argent qui va vous permettre de
payer vos loisirs et de payer vos
charges votre loyer l'assurance de votre
voiture
les sens les courses bon votre
rémunération vous apporte aussi le gain
d'un capital temps c'est le fameux temps
libre la rtt
la réduction du temps de travail un
dispositif que les salariés connaissent
bien
illustre à merveille cette des deux
capitales tant ce temps libre et plus ou
moins importants selon les métiers selon
selon li moi également
on n'a pas toujours tous les mois le
même temps lire eh bien elle se divise
en deux catégories le temps récréatif
donc qui va de pair avec votre
rémunération en argent
qui vous permet de financer vos loisirs
et le temps expérientiel entre autres
vital à la santé de votre bonne valeur
ajoutée alors qu'est ce que le temps
expérientiel au juste et bien c'est
toutes ces petites choses du quotidien
qui vous nourrissent le temps
expérientiel c'est un peu être un peu à
l'individu ce que la notion dit
nutrition et ta l'artiste laurie mills
aguets j'ai un trou 1898 pourrait aller
voir tout ça définit la nutrition comme
l'inspiration inconsciente d'un artiste
qui va puiser dans la culture qui
l'entourent et dont il s'est imprégné le
temps expérientiel garder en tête que
c'est l'ensemble des actions que les
verbes faire et bien être
résume faire la cuisine lire de la
poésie écrire lire voyager dessinée
contempler un paysage
toutes ces actions qui nous traversent
laisse en nous une trace vertueuse que
nous pourrons mobiliser dans nos
ouvrages professionnels afin de faire la
différence auprès de nos clients
oui mais voilà dans notre société de
vitesse le temps expérientiel est
souvent la première victime de notre
vélocité vous savez c'est un peu comme
comme le budget communication dans les
entreprises en général c'est la première
chose qu'ils sont le graphique que vous
avez derrière moi schématise la
répartition du temps de travail d'un
salarié sur un mois tip
alors résultats 73% de travail 27% de
temps libre le second graphique juste en
bas montre ce qu'il devrait être
idéalement c'est à dire 30 jours
dix-huit jours de temps de travail
quatre jours de temps récréatif et 8
j'entends expérientiel cela implique
donc de réaliser son chiffre en 18 jours
plus tôt quand 22 jours de remplacer le
temps récréatif du premier graphique
part du temps expérientiel et d'utiliser
le gain des quatre jours économisez sur
le temps de travail du premier graphique
comme du temps récréatif
alors si la deuxième équation c'est d'un
petit peu un jeu de chaises musicales
la deuxième nécessite une augmentation
du prix de vente moyen
alors pour être très concret au lieu de
facturer mes services 350 euros la
journée
eh bien je vais les factures et 430
esthétique
et bien pour moi la réponse est oui car
cette augmentation me permet de me payer
le luxe du temps expérientiel qui a un
impact bénéfique et direct sur la valeur
ajoutée et qui influence en plus
positivement la qualité de mon travail
seule condition à cette éthique que ce
temps libre ne soit pas un temps
d'oisiveté ni un temps récréatif mais
bien un temps dédié aux expériences
alors conclusion si mon client est en
attente de valeur ajoutée et qu'il me
faut du temps libre pour pouvoir nourrir
cette valeur ajoutée alors je vais
augmenter ma rémunération en argent pour
travailler moins longtemps
afin de satisfaire la tante de mon
client de ce toc
j'aimerais que vous reteniez pour
terminer trois choses tout d'abord que
c'est vous que c'est nous les moteurs de
demain et que c'est à nous qu'incombe la
responsabilité de développer de nouveaux
schémas de travail gagnant gagnant comme
celui que je viens de vous exposer et
qu'ils nous laisseront le temps de vivre
et de profiter de notre vie ensuite que
votre valeur ajoutée
vous êtes nombreux dans cette salle
votre valeur ajoutée elle est unique et
il y aura toujours un client sera la
recherche de cette exacte nuance que
vous seul porter dans votre palette
alors s'il vous plaît prenez le temps de
nourrir cette valeur ajoutée
d'expérience tous les jour
quotidiennement et enfin qu'il n'y a
rien de plus important que
l'épanouissement de soi
cet épanouissement qui vous permet de
vous élever en tant qu'individu et donc
en tant que professionnel
je vous remercie pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous pourrez très prochainement
retrouver tout le contenu de ce topic
sur ma page facebook
sûrement linkedin et je vous fais un
petit conseil pour terminer une petite
lecture je vous conseille de lire l'art
de ralentir pourra prendre le temps de
vivre de véronique aïcha merci bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]